so hello everybody last night we did the
first seminar of symbolism symbolism
that I'm setting up with with patreon
for for those that give 150 or more a
month and so I thought I would put up a
few clips of our discussion because it
was a lot of fun we talked about a lot
of things from movies to sex to to
cosmological symbolism and so I'm not
gonna put up the whole discussion I want
to respect the privacy of the people who
were involved in the discussion but I
thought I'd put up a few little clips
just to give you a taste of the things
we talked about and so for those who
haven't seen it my video of Logan was
blocked by Fox I put it up on D Tube for
now and so you can find a description in
I'll put it in this description what the
link to that D Tube video and we're
trying to re-edit it as well to see if
we can put it up on YouTube in a
different fashion and so yeah so enjoy
let's move on to the next that's one of
the next good question I don't know
they're all right so I assume you've
heard Peter search take on this story of
Pinocchio you agree in general with the
interpretation and do you think the
creator's purposefully shaped it like
that because they understood the deeper
meaning it would convey um well I agree
I agree with I agree with with Jordans
interpretation I think what's
interesting about the Pinocchio story is
that it's he's not really Jordan not
really interpreting the Pinocchio story
as such he's really interpreting
Disney's movie of Pinocchio
which is much more concise that the
story the actual Pinocchio story if you
read it it's rambling and it's like it's
chaotic and and it's it's it's like all
kinds of things mixed up and it's very
moralistic like it's super moralistic
it's basically about you know you need
to obey your parents and and go to
school and be a good boy kind of like
you know really 19th century style
moralism whereas whereas Disney's
version it does end up being more
archetypal and I think I think that I
think that Disney was one of those
people that definitely already had it
had a very profound intuition about
about stories you know she really boils
them down to they're they're kind of
essential characteristics and you know
for example like when they did Sleeping
Beauty no there's nothing in the in the
story of Sleeping Beauty which suggests
that the that the the Evil Queen is also
a dragon I've never seen I'd never seen
that before
but it makes absolute sense when you see
it play itself out you don't question it
for a second it makes absolute sense and
so it so I think that Disney I don't
know if he if it was on purpose and more
than he just had a very intuitive sense
of what makes sense in terms of in terms
of storytelling you know and so but he's
got he had to had some not and the fact
that he made the dwarves seven like
there was no there were there was no
tradition that the dwarves were savage
before Disney
[Music]
and so you know there and you know like
in the Disney version of Snow White for
example they really they really bring
the notion of the Apple and the notion
of seduction into play really strongly
because the the Queen when she goes to
see snow white she says she gives her
the Apple and she says something about
how like men love when you cook for them
or something like if you make an apple
pie for men that's how you'll get their
mark or something so she's able to like
to join that together also they bring
the prince in at the beginning which is
not in the the I've never heard that in
the snow white started before where she
sees the prince in the castle before and
so it's it's actually the the stepmother
who sees the prince being attracted to
Snow White which causes her to be her
first out of jealousy which that's not
in the end I've never seen that in the
like this is the book version of it yeah
so they really ties everything together
and brings in a psychological element
that's that's really kind of powerfully
tied into the more let's say
mythological structure that's oh I think
definitely Disney of all people had had
it had it going and and in terms of the
Pinocchio story I think that I think
that Jordans interpretation is is very
sound you know like he sees he sees this
idea of the one thing that's not sound
about Jordans interpretation this is
really coming from a Christian point of
view is that when Jordan talks about the
father he always talks about for the
father in the terms of God the Father
and he has this idea of going you know
of saving God the God the Father he
mixes up the no no God the Father and
let's say another version of the father
and and that's that's problematic
because God the Father in the Christian
tradition doesn't represent what he says
it represents it doesn't represent the
notion of like of a dead tradition let's
say or them kind of an aging tradition
when Christ goes into the underworld
when in the in them in the more
mythological version like there's a
there's an Apocrypha of the story of the
death and resurrection of Christ where
it actually describes Christ going down
into the underworld and then
resurrecting people well in Christ goes
down into the underworld he saves Adam
okay an atom is the father the father
that that Christ goes to save in the
underworld is is the old man Adam it's
the fallen is fallen ancestor is fallen
human ancestor and so it's there in the
story it's not I'm not making it up
that's this the Christian story that
when Christ goes into into death he goes
to save Adam and so that's the only
place where I disagree with Jordan in
terms of his interpretation of the
Pinocchio and the whole idea of going
down and and and saving your father from
the underworld
and so there's something about a
grotesque the idea of the grotesque as
as a way to you've seen that video where
I talk about them about the limit and
how the guardian of the limit shares
something in common with what's on the
other side it's on oh okay so think
about this like the guardian of the
guardian of the limit of Hell is
cerberus right is a dog it's a it's a
dog it's a it's a three-headed dog it's
a it's a monster so the monster the
monster is on the outside okay imagine
it this way this is the best way to see
it
imagine us level levels of monsters okay
imagine for this monster is like the
Leviathan okay and then what's what
stops the Leviathan let's say from
eating the world is is like a smaller
version of smaller dragon let's say then
what stops the dragon from eating our
world is like that say the dog headed
men and would stop the dog headed man
from eating our world or you know like a
foreign tribe that are far away from us
and then what stops the foreign tribe
from from from stopping us are the
guards who live on the border of our
land who suffer who live because they
live on the border of our land they send
to intermarry with those with their
enemy and they tend to mix with the
enemy but they also defend this from the
enemy okay so the best prison guard is a
prisoner does that make sense yeah Gulag
Archipelago yeah right okay so the bet
so the the best prison guard the best
limit is that which comes from the
outside which can be turned back against
the outside alright so chaos turned
against chaos in Christianity we talked
about we'd say it's death it's like the
idea of guests trampling down death or
death conquering death so that's what a
vaccine is that's what okay that's what
it that's what let's say in the Bible
there's this story in Adam and Eve about
the garments of skin so when Adam and
Eve fall
God gives them garments of skin so he
gives them a covering of dead skins to
put around them and that covering of
dead skins is a protection from death so
it's its death protecting from death
right now right and so I mean that's
what war is that's what you know
anything that anything that that is this
idea that death is like a buffer is both
is both that which will kill you but
that also that which will protect you
from it right so you can see it in terms
of supplement that's a good way to
understand it that you have
supplementarity and so and so you you
you you need to add okay so how can I
get explain this like let's say well
just the idea of medicine medicine is
exactly that and that all medicines are
poisons pretty much right medicine is
not food it is it and that's something
that you eat to to to to make your body
to to let's say form the matter of your
body medicine is a poison that you take
in little doses and at at in very
specific ways in order to stop something
that's going to kill you okay
and so all medicine is a for and it's
and it's something that you add to your
normal life in order to protect you from
death so you can see it as that you can
see it also as as as a house all right
so you take things from the earth you
take rocks out of the earth which is
your ultimate your ultimate place where
you're going to decompose in life and
then you build this thing around you to
stop death from getting you all right
Geoffrey you a viewer you wanted to have
something yeah I was just wondering or
maybe adding but but it's like
controlled chaos if I'm getting that
correct yeah exactly you can turn on the
be outside and maybe even greater chaos
yeah that's exactly the way to see it
another way and
image of that is the is a carnival
carnivals are controlled chaos and so
and so at the end of the year at the end
of a cycle you have a carnival where
everything is upside down for one day or
for one week or whatever and so it's
it's you you it's like you're giving a
dose of chaos and to the cycle in order
to just to prevent it from going into
absolute chaos right that's why you you
need that's why absolute order always
leads to absolute chaos you're supposed
to have you're supposed to leave a
buffer in the way the church is built
it's like that so you have the altar you
have the nave and you're the narthex